welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and ahsoka's final few episodes
have plunged Star Wars into witchcraft
necromancy and magic with a K which
going by how my parents spelled my name
is never a good sign the series just
dropped a huge Revelation that the death
of Mary the night sister witches that
include Morgan elsmith Maul's mother
mother tells him and from Jedi Fallen
order night sister Marin are part of a
lineage that did not originally come
from this galaxy but emigrated to the
planet of dothmir from their original
home of paridia in another galaxy a race
of witches from another galaxy the three
remaining witches I'm pretty are cooking
up something magic Co for thrawn that
probably involves as night Troopers and
some corpses in this video I'm gonna
explain why the death of Mary migrated
from viridia to this galaxy why some of
them stayed what they're most afraid of
and what we have the most appear from
them now before I begin a huge new
detail that I have to explain that was
pointed out to me by Tommy J Wall on
Twitter so in my episode 6 Easter egg
breakdown I spotted the written text on
the Fortress wall and I brought up the
Sith language of erkatach but Tommy
shared that if you rotate it 180 degrees
these letters actually translate from
erkata to the following phrase praise
kujit ruler of all may his Reign last
for ah probably all time huge thanks to
Tommy wall and for anyone else who
figured this out I guess I should have
stayed up till 4am instead of giving up
at 3am or maybe spent less time looking
at freaking hyperspace for blurs in the
shape of an in one Naboo Starfighter but
kujet kujet was the name of a zepho sage
and ruler the zifonians were an ancient
race from the game Jedi Fallen order and
kujit established a palace on the planet
gothamir and used the dark side of the
force what the zyphonians called the
life wind kujit had promised his
followers to share his knowledge but he
was very cruel and staged a massacre in
his Palace actually in the character
poster of thrawn released on Thursday
you can see this erk attack more clearly
so yeah it sounds like the zeppo built
this fortress on paridia as well which
is interesting because zepho is supposed
to be an outer rim planet in the main
Galaxy but based on this Palace
appearing on paridia it tells us that
the zifonians must have also traveled
this Pathway to Privia to this other
Galaxy met the Knight sisters and
established this Palace years before
thrawn got here and then maybe died out
sometime after or it's possible that the
people of zepho came from paridia made
this journey from paridia with the
Knight sisters to deathmere but I guess
Morgan L Smith just seemed to claim that
pridia was uniquely the home to the
death of Mary but she did say that the
death of Mary were one of the early
races to master Pergo hyperspace travel
it's just not clear yet which direction
this went but clearly the two peoples
were connected and this tells us that
the night sisters have a long history of
providing dark magic counsel to several
generations of Invaders whom they
inevitably Outlast like before it was
thrawn it was a separatist and before
the separatists it was the people of
zeppo and the night sisters are the
survivors so let's do a deep dive into
these surviving witches The Witches of
death mirror were originally introduced
in the 1994 novel The courtship of
Princess Leia by Dave Wolverton for
years they had been considered part of
the legend side of the Star Wars lore
but the Clone Wars series introduced a
coven of night sisters led by mother
thousand on the planet of dothmir talzin
being the mother of maul these night
sisters had white and gray they cases
they wore red robes using designs
originally could see for the Sith in The
Phantom Menace film but the sorcery they
wielded had long been considered to be
dark side-ish in nature connected to the
force but neither Jedi nor Sith
something independent something else
entirely the canonical history of
dothamir and the Knight sisters had
previously been compiled from variety
sources like collapse of the Jedi RPG
game Source book that included an
apocryphal account of a Jedi Council
Outcast named Alia who supposedly
founded the coven on deathmere but the
night sisters themselves had always had
their own legends about their origins in
Clone Wars we learned that mother Towson
United all the night sister Clans on
deathmere and had worked closely with
Darth Sidious to learn secrets about the
force from the sit but Sidious betrayed
her and took her son Maul taking him on
as his Sith Apprentice now talzin had
actually given birth to Maul as well as
his brother Savage press and another
Knight brother named Farrell but these
brothers were all the native dothamerian
race of zabrook with the interesting
skin patterns and the horns the night
sisters were not zabrak in race in
Ahsoka episode 6 finally explains why
they were not native to dothmir they
were dothamiri from the planet paridia
in another galaxy migrated to this
Galaxy and set up shop at a planet later
known as deathmere named after their
race not the other way around now Clone
Wars revisits the planet deathmare a
number of times as the Dooku acolyte as
such Ventress was originally part of the
night sisters Maul returns there of
course when his half robotic form is
found by his brother Savage and tals
into the night sisters use sorcery to
reanimate Mall's legs the night sister
sent Savage after Dooku at one point and
in Clone Wars season 4 episode 19
Massacre General Grievous retaliated
destroying their Fortress in a majority
of night sisters in the Battle of
daphmir during this battle knight's
sister old DACA resurrects an army of
the Dead militarizing undead zombie
night sisters but this plan fails and
the night sisters lose the battle and
the only survivors really are of
Interest who gets baptized as the night
sister at this point talzin and a few
others we later learn about like Marin
from Jedi Paul in order and Morgan
ellsbeth thousand would later die in the
events of the mall son of dothamir
comics while trying to work with Maul to
kill Sidious and Dooku now the Ahsoka
series is extending the night sister
lore redefining them as the oldest known
civilization in Star Wars canonical
history predating it sounds like the
zephonians explored in Jedi Fallen order
as well as predating the Jedi and the
Sith perhaps even older than races like
there were Cottons Invaders who invented
hyperspace technology introduced in
Knights of the Old Republic and
confirmed an Andor to be somewhat Canon
now long time new Rockstar's viewers
know how much we use geology and how
long we've been using it for but if this
is your first time hearing about geology
get ready for Blockbuster quality Skin
Care on a student film budget geology is
a 23-time award-winning skin hair and
body care company recognized in men's
health Oprah daily hypebeast birdie
Esquire and GQ geology's products are
just a handful of powerful proven
ingredients that have been trusted by
dermatologists for decades geology can
help you fight acne reduce oil-ness
prevent wrinkles combat dark or puffy
under eyes have smoother hydrated skin
and Target signs of aging everything you
need to keep your skin healthy no matter
how much you soak in the pool this
summer don't know where to start geology
can create a a simple and effective skin
care or hair care routine for you all
you gotta do is take a quick 30 second
quiz right now if you use the code new
rockstars 100 geology will give you 100
off their award-winning skincare trial
set you'll also get an additional bonus
offer of up to 30 off one skin hair or
body products when you add it to your
trial it's truly a while to offer one of
the best they've ever given our audience
so click the link in the description or
go to
geolog.i.e rockstars 100 to get started
and asok episode one Morgan tells balen
and shin about the temple on Arcana what
was this place an ancient temple built
by my ancestors the ninth sisters of
daphnea you're a witch a survivor in
episode six they complete the pathway to
peridia the ancient Homeworld of my
ancestors the death of Mary and Morgan
says that the night sisters have a long
history with the purple hyperspace
whales my people were among the first to
harness and ride the creatures in the
days before time was counted the prayer
previous surface we find out Is A
Wasteland dotted with these tall pillars
that evoke the columns on malachor in
Rebels season 2 finale each column
though is topped with a ghoulish Knight
sister statue head mouths contorted open
in a permanent scream Morgan unites with
the three great mothers named clotho
lakisis and actropod named after the
three big Greek mythology aka the morai
and in my episode breakdown I pointed
out how their headdresses might reflect
to the Greek mythological functions of
the Fate who spins the thread with a
single pointed needle and the Fate who
cuts the thread with shears these great
mothers can sense future events calling
it the thread of fate and they are
particularly disgusted with the Jedi it
reeks of the Jedi it is dangerous later
in the episode Baylin and shin discuss
how the great mothers are desperate to
leave paridia they seem eager to leave
this place
maybe we should too and in the final
scene of this episode thrawn drop some
interesting words about the night
sisters death and Resurrection are
common deceptions played out by both
nice sister and Jedi and learning that
Ahsoka is approaching he asks I should
once again require the aid of your dark
magic the thread of Destiny demands it
Grand Admiral so the coppins that thrawn
Stormtroopers move from the paridian
catacombs to his Star Destroyer the
Chimera seemed to be part of a night
sister plot to do what all DACA and
mother talzin did to resurrect an army
of the Dead moroque was revealed to be a
knight brother corpse made up of green
night sister sorcery that dirty broken
beat up look of these Stormtroopers
seems to be a nod to the night troopers
from the Legends book death troopers
from Joe Schreiber Troopers that were
infected with the kind of zombie virus
the red bandages that wrap up these
Troopers might be part of their sorcery
not just to hold their armor together
but to hold their bodies together thrawn
indicated that his numbers were
dwindling and was reluctant to send out
more than two units to support Balin and
shin and I think that is why these
Troopers may all be dead and brought him
underneath that armor I think these
Stormtroopers are zombified corpses
animated by night sister sorcery and the
confidence contained corpses of past
night sisters and Knight Brothers that
the great mothers plan to reanimate as
well but the big mystery is why the
night sisters originally left paridia
for the Galaxy we know with the planet
dothamir my theory is that they could be
descended from the five priestesses of
the Wellspring of light the origin of
midichlorians which was explored by Yoda
in Clone Wars season 6. I like the idea
of an evil sixth Priestess that was
exiled to paridia or maybe even the
Priestess that represented the emotion
of sadness because her mouth is
stretched open just like those statues
on the planet apridia and that this
priestess's followers always wanted to
get back to that Garden of Eden because
that Wellspring seemed to be unique to
the main Galaxy so by that logic does
paridia a graveyard planet and a
different Galaxy where Pergo go to die
does that place have a shortage or a
lack of midichlorians that would limit
the witch's power because midichlorians
are how we connect to the force and that
might explain why only three can live
there at any given time and the rest
would have to migrate closer to the
epicenter of the cosmic force in fact
might be why Morgan ellsmith called
herself a Survivor so what new magic is
thrawn requesting for the great mothers
we still do not know who exactly pulled
Ahsoka into the world Between Worlds and
what exactly Anakin was this could have
been the result of Knight's sister's
sorcery which was burned into ahsoka's
Hand by that night sister spear now
maybe thrawn wants the great mothers to
send Ahsoka back in the world Between
Worlds to reconfront another past foe
information that he could get by
morganelle's been digging up everything
that she can find on Ahsoka and that foe
would be some of the night sisters have
a history with Maul and then instead of
the blue watery texture to the world
Between Worlds this time it could be red
and fiery we will see please support our
Channel by grabbing an Ahsoka inspired
fulcrum shirt available at nerd
riot.shop please subscribe to the break
room for episodes of Wookie leaks or
Ahsoka after show you can subscribe to
all three channels on the new rockstars
Network follow me at eavos fall into
rockstars thanks for watching I'll see
you next time bye
[Music]
thank you